drop out and get schooled the case for
thinking twice about college
I am literally holding on to the
manuscript of this book drop out and get
schooled and it is amazing I've written
a lot of different things I've spoken
about a lot of different things that's
created heat controversy hate mail all
this other stuff I talked about how Real
Estate's not the Americans all these
other things I've talked about nothing
has created this much hate mail and
messages from academia universities
publishers as this podcast I haven't
even published this book yet and it's
creating damn much it let me show you
the cover this book here and I'll take
the story drop out and get schooled the
case we're thinking twice about college
so I'm gonna tell you why this inspired
me just about a year and a half ago I
made a video called drop out or stay in
school because a lot of people that ask
me questions should I stay in school or
should I get out as an entrepreneur and
when I made that video I got a lot of
commentary fortune contacted me Forbes
CNN Fox everybody that we're doing
interviews and all these things and I
was giving my thoughts and eventually I
said I must start writing this book and
I did I wrote the book and once I wrote
the book I started contacting publishers
because I wanted a publishing house to
pick it up and one publisher said okay
great let me read it he read it they got
back to us very very big everybody knows
who they are and so we got on a call
with them so initially I'm thinking
they're interested in publishing this
book I said sure let's get on a call
so I said tell me your thoughts about
the book and he starts up asking me
questions and why'd you write it why
this why don't tell her my thoughts and
then next thing you know a conversation
leads to an all-out debate and this guy
I haven't seen anyone this furious it's
he's a guy that gets paid to publish
books that gonna do well how dare you
write a book about school like this how
dare you write about I can do you know
how prestigious it is to go to
university you've never even been to
college you don't have any right to
write a book about dropping out of
college you ought to be ashamed of
yourself and I'm listening to this guy
and I'm sinner saying who is this guy
talking to seeing all this stuff he says
if you've never been to college if
you've never got a four-year degree you
are
never write a book like this so I leave
and I said okay fair enough no problem
what do I do I come back I contact Tom
Ellsworth my good friend let me say
about Tom elsewhere Tom Miller went to
Cal State University got us four-year
degree then he went to Pepperdine
University got his MBA eventually became
an adjunct professor at Pepperdine
University and adjunct is when you
become a professor but you don't have a
PhD you have an MBA then he goes into
business and eventually starts with
jammed at him and seven other guys take
Jam that and they sell it for six
hundred and eighty million dollars to EA
Sports and then he starts a couple other
companies now he's one of my friends and
a partner of mine that we do business
west Tom I want you to give you a
perspective on this and he does as well
so then I took the story back to the
same publishing house and other people I
said here you go with the book let me
put it to you this way initially I
thought they were furious whatever
happened they shared this with other
people and we've got non-stop email
after email after email about how much
hate they have and how much they're
prepared to absolutely blemish the name
and thar you know or tarnish the name if
we go live with I can't even believe
this I can't even believe this and maybe
they don't know the personality too well
and so I'm telling you all this stuff
because I won't tell you why I wrote
this book and why this is getting me so
fired up because look I have been in
business now for many years in a
financial industry and as a person
that's been a financial adviser since
the day before 9/11 I have my serious
766 31:26 life and health I started off
with Morgan Stanley Dean would have sit
in front of thousands and thousands of
people who have managed their finances
and when I go through it how much money
having your 401k savings investments
insurance assets annuities stocks bonds
options checking savings CDs
debt card that mortgage everything I go
through and it comes to school own and
they'll tell me how much having a school
onalaska they'll say $110,000 and I
always ask this one question what was
your degree in they'll tell me and ask
does your job have anything to do with
your degree maybe one out of ten
they say yes one out of ten times they
say yes one out of ten times they say
yes and I say one out of ten times so
has come tell me what was your
experience like and then people start
selling me on why they made the right
decision here's what they typically say
I made some my best friends in college
you're gonna make best friends at that
age no matter where you go in the
military a lot of friends oh you know I
learned so much about human nature you
didn't learn about human nature all you
got to do is go through a couple
breakups I learned so much about you
know when I moved away from my family I
learn about independence you could have
gone back back in some worlds but no one
tells me the class I took in physics
taught me about life decisions come on
des and here we are with these massive
institutions who take $40,000
comfortably from 18 year-old naive kids
that haven't even lived life yet they
haven't even paid taxes yet to know the
pain of taxes and they get there and
they say all these things about rich
people greedy people capital of some
entrepreneurs they're bad people all
this other stuff while we're paying
forty grandeur for them to go to school
and they're feeding all this stuff to
these eighteen year old kids and they
come out at twenty-two stuck with a
hundred and ten hundred fifty thousand
dollar loan that they got to pay off but
these colleges get to write everything
off because it's a non-profit what a
beautiful business I mean let me tell
you something if you want to get into
business start a college truly if you
want to be a billionaire go start a
college a lot of these colleges have a
lot of billions of dollars they're
sitting on that they paid this much
taxes to but media doesn't want to talk
about it and so I'm sitting here with
this book and I have some conflicted
emotions thoughts as you can tell I'm
pretty frustrated with the fact that
here we are a message like this which is
not a political message let me put it to
you this way Republicans disagree with
the educational system
so do liberals both sides Trump didn't
like it Bernie Sanders they don't like
it and Bernie Sanders champion the whole
message about why we're having kids
having so much college did accept this
message was for taxpayers to pay for it
and I completely disagree with that as
well why should tax wet tax payers pay
so much money for colleges to make money
why should we give colleges so much
money what grants them the right to make
all this money so this is not a
Republican thing this is not a
democratic thing this is not
independent libertarian thing this is an
international thing that it's time for
us to start asking the questions that
people are afraid of asking why for
years
why physics why anthropology for a four
year degree in communication why even a
degree tell me why a business person
needs to go to school and have a
professor who's never ran a business
teach them out how to run a business I
don't get that and if I'm the only one
here that's asking these questions then
I'm the dummy here but I don't think I'm
the only one here I just don't and so
it's 11 see what time I see you right
now it's 11:20 right now my wife is
sleeping inside with the kids I just got
home and this is all my mind and I
haven't fully decided whether
republishing this or not I haven't fully
decided whether we're publishing this or
not because I do know once this goes
live there's gonna be a lot of people
are gonna disagree with this lots of
people that are gonna hate this entire
topic and when you read it we have stats
we have facts we have stories we have
people's point of view we give both
sides of the argument a drop out versus
Tom who didn't drop out and when it got
us for your enough's NBA and Fiji
followed everything to the system and he
tells the story about him and his father
and of in the book that's fascinating
and we give formulas and if you do drop
out what else do you do so I have a
feeling that if this comes out there's a
whole drop out revolution that can
happen around the world it's already
happening what people who follow value
taemin I've gotten messages from parents
that say Patrick please don't publish
this book because our kids admire you
please don't publish it teachers my
former teachers have messaged me saying
what's happened to you have you bought
into money on in unlike the money truly
are you really selling me on the fact
that I've bought into money while so
many people are getting a damn divorce
because they don't have their finances
in order because they're stuck with a 93
thousand dollar debt to college that
they're paying for and you telling me
that I bought it to money come on man
come on man my parents got a divorce I
know what it feels like to be raised in
a family that mom and dad don't have any
money in order my dad's a cashier at a
99-cent store and my mom did anything to
bring us to America to escape Iran and
we had welfare and all this stuff and
have to join the army because my mother
ran out of money went back to Iran I was
homeless for 21 days begging friends to
live at their places so don't talk to me
about
don't talk to me about my money I'm
trying to help other people say don't go
through that process and I think it's
time for us to have this conversation so
look I just honestly I just have a heavy
heart I don't have any I'm just simply
asking you what are your thoughts if we
do publish this book what are your
thoughts about the current educational
system should we publish this book we
will make a firm decision 48 hours from
now Tom and I need to sit down and talk
my family and I need to sit down and
talk because I do know this thing's
gonna go nuts when it comes out it's not
a 300 page book it is a hundred forty
hundred fifty page book but if we go we
do go alive with this book it's not
because I'm trying to make another fifty
thousand dollars or twenty thousand
dollars and if you know anything about
books books don't make a lot of money
they don't make a lot of money and I'm
not gonna wait 18 to 24 months cuz one
publisher said we'll publish it for you
but well 18 to 24 months I can't wait 18
to 24 months this is a message that I
think the world needs to hear about so
tell me your thoughts publish or don't
publish drop out and get schooled I want
to hear from you